[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS CRALL: Today,
Jianfei, who is sitting here
in the front row, and I will
be talking about hybrid mesh.
So how do we add VMs
to our environment?
Can I get a show of hands?
How many have you been to an
Istio talk here at the show?
OK.
Great.
We'll probably
repeat a few things.
But there were some people
who didn't raise their hands.
So we'll do some level setting
as well as we go through here.
OK, here's the summary.
This is all you
need to remember.
Istio works on VMs.
If that's the only thing
you get out of this talk,
that's the thing I want you
to walk out of this room with.
Istio does work on VMs.
So most of you that have
been to Istio presentations
here, you've read
articles, you've
read the documentation
about Istio.
For the most part, it
talks about Kubernetes.
So how does Istio
work on clusters?
We're going to show you how
to extend that to VMs today.
So I said we'd do a little
bit of level setting.
So first, let's talk
about what Istio is just
for those people
that are new to this.
And to talk about Istio, we have
to talk about a service mesh.
So what is a service mesh?
Service meshes work
at the network layer.
So you put them in.
They are transparent
to the application.
That mean we don't care what
language the application is
written in, whether it's Java
or C# or Go or Node or whatever.
It just doesn't
matter because we're
working at the network layer.
And the mesh provides some
level of functionality.
Whether it's telemetry
or some network controls,
a service mesh provides
that kind of capability.
And there are many
service meshes out there.
Istio is probably
the most common one
that you've heard about.
But there are other
service meshes as well.
So let's talk about
Istio specifically then.
It is a service mesh.
But we think it's
much more than that.
It's an open services
platform because we've
designed so many sensibility
points into Istio, again,
it works on containers and VM.
So we can bring in
the full environment.
You can plug in different
monitoring solutions.
You can plug in all kinds
of access control solutions.
So it really is a platform that
allows you to really control
your services, both what's
going on at the network level
and monitoring all
that information.
So what is the value
proposition of Istio then?
We break it down into
these three things,
uniform observability.
Because we're at
the network layer,
we see all the network
traffic, and we know
what's going on on the network.
And we can send all that
telemetry information
to the Mixer, which is
part of the control plane.
And the Mixer then
can forward it
on to wherever you want that
telemetry information to go,
whether that's Stackdriver on
GCP, or Prometheus, or Datadog,
or wherever you want your
logging information to go,
we can do that
through the Mixer.
We provide operational agility.
So that means that you
can do canary rollouts.
You can do blue/green rollouts.
You can inject faults
into the network
if you want to test the
resiliency of your services.
You can set quotas.
If you've ever had a
service accidentally
do a DoS attack on one
of your other services,
then you might want to set
quotas on your services.
And then the third thing we can
do is policy-driven security.
So we can set encryption on
this-- on all the communication
going on on the network.
So we use mutual TLS.
That means we set strong
identities for the service.
We know the identity of every
service running in the mesh.
And we know that service
A is talking to service B.
And so you see that service
B is talking to service C.
And you may think service
A is talking to service C.
But again, by looking
at the telemetry,
you could see, maybe that's
not happening for some reason.
So we can do all
three of these things.
And these are very important
value props of Istio.
OK, as I mentioned, most
of the documentation,
most of the things you see about
Istio talk about a cluster.
And our control plane
runs in Kubernetes.
So I've got Kubernetes
shown in the middle here.
But as you probably know, most
of the Enterprise workloads
actually still run on VMs.
And there are lots of
good reasons for that.
The first one is Datastores.
So when I talk to customers,
probably the first thing
that comes up is Datastores.
They're running their MySQL,
their Postgres, their Oracle
database, their Cassandra,
their Couchbase, whatever it is.
And there is a whole
laundry list of them.
Many, many Datastores
run on VMs today.
And many Enterprises
have no intention
of moving those
in the near-term.
Some people are moving
them to Kubernetes.
And Kubernetes is much
better now with those.
But a lot of them
are still on VMs
and will be for quite a while.
Then there's packaged software.
It's a black box, right?
You get it from some
vendor, whether it's
a CRM application, an HR
application, whatever it is.
The vendor says, this needs to
run on this release of Linux.
It needs X amount of
RAM, X amount of CPU.
That's where you'll run
it if you want support.
So as a company, you really
don't have any choice.
That's going to run on a VM.
There is existing software.
Enterprises have
written lots of software
on VMs in the last year, in the
last five years, the last 10
years.
Those services are running.
They will be for a long time.
And new applications are being
written on VMs all the time.
In most of your
Enterprises, you guys
are still writing
software on VMs
and rolling out
new applications.
So we really want to bring all
these things into the Istio
mesh and provide all those
value props to you on these VMs.
OK.
So that's kind of the setup
and the level setting.
So the rest of this
is really going to be,
so how do we do that?
How do we bring VMs
into this environment?
So this diagram is a
picture of a Kubernetes
cluster with Istio.
It's a simplified
representation.
I just show two services on
here, service 1 and service 2.
Now each one of those services
is some number of pods.
Let's say service 1 is three
pods, and service 2 is 10 pods.
Because we have Istio running
on here, those services,
those pods are running
Istio sidecars as well.
So imagine service
1 and service 2
are broken out into
those pods and they're
running the Istio sidecars.
We have the control
plane components here
on the right, Mixer,
Pilot, and Citadel.
Pilot is pushing out the policy
to all the Istio sidecars.
It's the one that tells
it how to direct traffic
and all those kind of things,
what the security policy should
be.
Mixer is getting
all the requests
from the Istio sidecars
and the proxies.
It's getting all that
telemetry information
and then forwarding on to--
in what Jianfei will
show you in a minute
is Prometheus in our case.
And then Citadel is the CA,
the Certification Authority.
So it's providing
the certificates
for the strong authentication
between services.
Over on the left are
the ingress and egress
gateways into and
out of the cluster.
So this is what a standard
Kubernetes cluster looks
like with Istio installed.
And again, for those of you
that have been to other talks,
this is kind of where
this story stops.
But what we want to do is
bring in VMs into this story.
So again, two more simple
services on here, service 3
and service 4.
So how do we add
VMs to this world?
Well, there is some
setup we have to do.
And we obviously have to
install some software.
We're going to put the
Envoy proxy on to these VMs.
I don't actually show it,
but there's another component
that goes on the VMs as well.
It's the node agent.
And that's the thing
that talks to Citadel
and is doing the certificate
renewal and so forth.
So we have the Envoy proxy,
the node agent that we
get installed on the VMs.
And then we have
to tell the cluster
how to communicate with
the VMs and the VMs
how to communicate
with the cluster.
So one of the important
things in that scenario
is this service entry.
So you see these
little boxes here
by the arrows that
go to the VMs?
Those are service entries.
A service entry
is a CRD that gets
installed into the cluster
as part of the Istio install.
So let's take a look at that.
So I mentioned, it's a CRD.
It's a Configurable
Resource Definition.
This is the way you extend
Kubernetes and tell it
about new resources.
This is a service entry.
It's what?
20 lines of YAML or so.
And this is all we
need to do to supply
the cluster with information
about services on VMs.
So some specific
information in here.
The top box there
is the ServiceEntry.
That just says what type of
configurable resource this is.
So again, this is the
extension to Kubernetes.
And then we're going to
provide some information
about what the service is.
In this case, the
name of the service,
I just grabbed this YAML right
out the Istio documentation.
So it's a simple example.
The name is the vmhttp.
We have to tell it what
the fully-qualified name
of the host is.
So here is vmhttp dot
SERVICE_NAMESPACE.
So again, we're dealing with
a Kubernetes control plane.
And Kubernetes has namespaces.
So we have to tell it where
this service is going to live,
what namespace it's
going to live in.
You can create a new
namespace for your VMs.
You can put it in
existing namespaces.
I think, actually the demo
you'll see in a few minutes
just uses the default namespace.
But it's totally up to you.
You just have to put these
things in a namespace.
And then some more
information about what
the address of the
actual host is,
you need to know how
to communicate with it.
So we have the GCE_IP address.
And then we have some labels.
So again, Kubernetes
uses labels.
And Istio uses labels for
things like canary rollouts
and directing traffic.
So we're going to add some
labels to this service as well.
So that's all there
is to a service entry.
Again, fairly short.
You just do a kube control
apply to enter this information
into the Kubernetes cluster.
So let's pop back a level.
We drove down into the CRD.
But let's talk about
what you actually
have to do for the full setup
of adding a VM to your service
mesh.
And this is right from
the Istio documentation.
This is just a summary of this.
So first, you have to
enable mesh expansion.
This is just a Boolean
flag on the Istio install.
By default, mesh
expansion is turned off.
You just have to turn it on.
It's a one-time operation
for the first VM you add.
And then if you add another
100 VMs, it doesn't matter.
You don't have to
change that flag.
You have to choose a
namespace for where these VMs
services are going to go.
As I showed in that CRD, when
you register the service,
you have to say what
namespace that service
is associated with.
You have to add the IP of the
ingress gateway to the cluster
to the VM.
So the VM is going to
communicate with the control
plane.
It needs to know where to send
the telemetry information.
That information goes to Mixer.
And so we're going
to get to Mixer
through the ingress
gateway in the cluster.
So you have to tell the VM
where that ingress gateway is.
You're obviously going
to have to install
the software on the VM, the
proxy, and the node agent.
You can do that just
through the package install.
And then step 6 and 7, these
are either/or or maybe both.
Step 6 is if you
have a VM that's
talking to services
inside the cluster--
so the communication
is going from the VM
to the service in the cluster--
then you have to tell the
VM where that service is.
So you just add its IP
address and information
to [INAUDIBLE] hosts in the
sample we're going to show you.
The other cases where you've got
the cluster talking to the VM,
this is a very common case,
this is that Datastore case
that I talked to
customers about.
So they've got, say, a Postgres
database running on a VM
that they need to
access from the cluster.
So now you have to tell
the cluster services
how to get to the VM.
You just create
that service entry,
that YAML file I talked
about, do a kube control apply
on that file.
And then you have
to add the address
to the DNS in the cluster.
So that's all there is to it.
It's fairly simple.
And actually, Jianfei
is going to show you
exactly how to do that.
So we're going to go
through two demos.
The first one is the setup.
The second one is
the Hipster app.
And again, if you've been
to other presentations,
you've probably seen
the Hipster app already.
This is just an
e-commerce website where
you can go and buy things.
All the other demos have
had all these services
running on the cluster,
so in Kubernetes.
And again, you can
see, they're written
in lots of different languages.
It doesn't matter.
At Istio, we can get
all the telemetry
and do all the controls
no matter the language.
I've circled one
in the bottom here,
this catalog service where
Jianfei is going to show you,
is that catalog service
running on a VM?
And then he's even going
to go further and show you
some traffic redirection.
So Jianfei?
JIANFEI HU: Thank you, Chris.
Hi, everyone.
My name's Jianfei.
I'm working at Google
Istio open source project.
Today, I will show
you the demo of how
to install the
Istio for this setup
and then run some
Istio feature to manage
your microservice across VM
and the Kubernetes cluster.
OK.
Let's switch to the demo.
So first of all, for all
the instructions and setup
that I'm doing today, you
can find the information
on istio.io website.
And here you can find
the setup and how
to run the workloads on the
VM and what kind of operations
you need to for
this kind of setup.
So please check it out.
And so the app, as
you probably already
heard of a lot of times at Next,
that is the Hipster Shop app.
People can come to this website.
And it shows the favorite
items you'd like and pick up
to your cart and check it out.
So it works perfectly.
Everything-- this is
a microservice-based
architecture.
Everything is a microservice.
They are communicating with
each other using grpc protocols.
And if you enable Istio,
you get all the benefits
of the Istio security,
telemetry, and traffic
management out of the box.
Great!
So except one thing, the
product catalog services
somehow still runs on the VM.
And you still want to wire
things together and behave
as a single mesh.
So we are going to just do it.
So the first thing,
of course, you
need to use a GCP_PROJECT
because this is Next.
And you need to
choose a GKE cluster.
choose a GC VM that
is hosting the VM
application workload We
are doing that setup with
some environment variable.
Sorry.
This should be Hipster
product catalog.
All right.
And by the way, for
today's demos purpose,
I prepare a bare script to
automate a lot of steps,
but essentially, that
it's all the same as a
what you can find on
istio.io web page.
Let's take a look
how that very quick,
that batch automation
looks like.
So pretty much that you can see
we need to create the cluster
and create the GC VM,
download the Istio,
and then install Istio.
So there's nothing
special over there.
That's just go back to the
demo and use the automation.
Cool.
So first of the first,
you need to install Istio
with mesh expansion enabled.
We'll run this setup.
And this will try to download
Istio and use your GKE cluster,
install the Istio with
its special [INAUDIBLE],,
enable the mesh expansion.
As Chris just mentioned that
the Istio mesh expansion to run
the VM, you essentially need
to expose the Istio control
plane to the VM workloads such
that as the Envoy on the VM
know how to communicate with the
Istio control plane like pilot
to get the Envoy
XDS configuration.
Istio knows the agent
then can also reach out
to the CA, Citadel
in the cluster
to get key and serve refreshed.
And also for the Mixer, you need
to report the telemetric data
back to Prometheus.
Great.
So we just finished
the installation.
And now we need to do another
thing to set up the GC VM.
We will run another
command for that purpose.
As you can see, other than
command, we have a 3550 port.
That is the port value the
VM applications, the product
catalog service, specifically,
that will listen on 3550.
And let's go ahead and see
what we are doing there.
The first thing is to get some
configuration from the cluster,
determine the IP range of
the service in the cluster.
And the second thing is to
get the key insert for this VM
workload.
Remember, Chris just
mentioned that you
need to choose a namespace
and a service account
to represent the
workload on the VM
as that VM workload identity.
So for our demo's
purpose, we just
choose the default and
the default service
account, default namespace.
But you can choose
whatever you like.
Cool.
So this two kind
of configuration
now is dumped into
your workstation.
And then you need
to copy it over
to your GC VM, which is
essentially just a GCloud
compute SEP command line.
You can see that a
bunch of configuration
has been copied to
the GC instance.
Once we have all those
configuration being copied
over, now is the time to run
some automation on the GC
instance.
So this part of the script
now will be running inside
of that VM instance.
So as you can see that we
expose the-- put the gateway IP,
a public IP, onto
the /etc/hosts.
So the Envoy can use
a name, Istio dash
pilot to resolve the address
of the Istio control plane
through gateway.
And this part is just trying
to download the Istio Debian
package that will be installed
on the VM operating system.
And we also need to copy the
key, cert to the designated
file system pass for the
Envoy to talking [INAUDIBLE]..
All right.
And the very last step,
after you set up everything,
you can now start
the Istio component
on the VM which
specifically is just
Istio Envoy used for intercept
of the traffic and Istio node
agent that is responsible
for refreshing
the key and cert
before it expires.
That's it.
Let's see second step.
So now you have both Istio
installed in your Kubernetes
cluster and you
have the VM that is
ready to run some applications.
Actually, if you
just type some--
run your applications
on that VM,
the Envoy is ready to
intercept the traffic.
And you can find
the other service.
It's in the Kubernetes cluster.
And we are ready to go.
However, there is one
thing that is missing,
that is the service discovery.
As Chris just mentioned,
because for the applications
that inside of the
Kubernetes cluster,
they don't know there is some
service running on this VM.
We need kind of service
discovery mechanism
to model these VM services.
The Istio, to handle
this as we know--
just learned-- it's
using a service entry.
So we basically need to write
some CRD of the service entry
to map a VM service to
a list of the endpoints.
So here we choose the name of
the services, product catalog
services.
And the port value is 3550,
match what we just used.
And the protocol is the grpc.
That is the three
arguments for this command.
Great.
We just did that.
So this essentially
do two things.
First is to create a service
entry to this IP of the VMs.
And the second thing is
to create a Kubernetes
service, selector service.
The purpose of that
is that when you
create a service in the
Kubernetes cluster, it will--
the Kubernetes is able to
return a corresponding DNS
record for the workload in the
Kubernetes cluster to resolve.
So the Kubernetes
applications can
use the names instead of IPs.
And so let's take a look what's
the service entry we just
generated looks like.
All right.
Sorry.
Need to upload the YAML file.
All right.
So as you can see--
probably need to
scroll up a little bit.
[INAUDIBLE] So this is
the service entries CRD.
And the name is product
catalog service dashboard VM.
We use that denote it's a
service running on the VM.
And you can see
in the spec ports,
the first is the endpoints.
The endpoints list the
list of the endpoints
that is responsible for
backing up this service.
In each endpoint, you can
specify the IP address,
which is, in our case,
is the VM IP address
to run the Hipster
product catalog service.
And you can also put
the labels over there.
Labels, you are familiar
with Kubernetes,
is you can put the
denotation on the deployment.
And you can use labels to select
Manage your workload later.
And as you can see, here
we put the register column
rawvm labels here.
And we are take advantage of
that in our follow-up demo.
And, of course, we need
to specify the host,
the name of the service.
And the port is 3550.
Protocol is grpc.
And that's it.
Cool.
So actually, now that is
pretty much everything
you need to do for the
VM setup mesh dimension.
And, of course, you need to
run your applications product
catalog service on that VM.
But we are going to skip that
part and switch to a cluster
that we already
finished that part.
So for these Hipster
app, everything
is passed through
a frontend ingress.
And here is the public IP
of the frontend ingress.
Let's send some
requests to this app
to see what is going on there.
So you keep hit the Refresh
button couple of times.
And, oh, OK, so here we go.
As we can see, sometimes it will
show a list of the products.
Sometimes, it only
shows one product.
Why that is the case?
Because we actually
runs a product catalog
service on both Kubernetes
cluster and on the GC VM.
In some sense,
this single service
is spinning all across
different platforms,
whether it's from the VM or
it's on Kubernetes cluster.
From a mesh point of
view, it doesn't matter.
And so to create a visual
very distinguishable effect,
we curated the items to
only retain one product
item on the VM version.
And then for the Kubernetes one,
we have more products for you
to buy from.
And if you're not
by the default case,
then you are now using any
advanced virtual service
kind of routing configuration.
It's randomly select either
one of the endpoint, either VM
endpoint or the pod in
the Kubernetes cluster.
So it's 50 by 50 chance.
And we will see that
through the dashboard later.
Cool.
So now let's send some traffic
to simulate the real customer
traffic.
We have a Python script
to generate some traffic
against that frontend.
So let's stop.
Let me explain a
little bit of what
this Python script is doing.
So this Python script is sending
some requests to the front end
and parse the HTML.
And if it is only
return one items,
then we know it is from the VM.
And if it is returns
more items, then it
is from Kubernetes cluster.
So in such a way that we can
count the accumulated requests
that is either handled
by the Kubernetes cluster
or they handled by
the VM workload.
And so as you can see,
this is roughly 50 and 50.
There's just pure random.
We're going to just run
these scripts continuously
to generate some traffic.
Now as you know, of the
value proposition for Istio
is to have the out of
box telemetry feature.
And let me show you on
the Grafana dashboard.
So here is the Grafana.
Probably, I need to
zoom in a little bit.
So we chose the namespace
default, which--
and the workload,
we can see here,
there is both
productcatalogservice
and product catalog
dash rawvm and there
is productcatalogservice.
The upper part of
this part result
is the Kubernetes version
that is using the Kubernetes
deployment name to
denote the workload name.
And the second part
is matches what
we used in the service entry.
And we used this
for the VM workload.
Less refresh it a little bit.
As you can see that--
so it has some qps 2 qps.
And this is the response
by response code, it 200.
And it works great.
Let's do another
tab, side by side,
to see the traffic that is
running on the Kubernetes
cluster.
And it's 3 qps.
So it's no that's accurate,
but it is roughly at like 50%
by 50%.
So you get the telemetry
feature from the Istio.
Now let's say you want
to protect your traffic.
You want to enable the mutual
TLS handled by the Envoy.
You don't need to do anything
on your applications.
So for that, we are just write
some authentication policy.
So as some of you
familiar with the Istio,
we use authentication policy
to configure the server side
security requirement.
Basically, we say, for this
service, for these part,
we require you to either--
the client needs to
talk in mutual TLS
or you need to give
me a [INAUDIBLE]..
For our purpose, we are
just using mutual TLS
And we have some CRD here.
Let's take a look at
how that looks like.
The policy specified the
productcatalogservice.
And the mutual TLS we specify
the mode as the strict.
Also, that is for server-side
requirements that clients,
you please talk in mutual
TLS, otherwise I will reject.
And for the client side,
that is the destination rule.
Destination rule tells how
the client Envoy, what kind
of mutual TLS settings
you need to use when
talk to the specific server.
So we specify ISTIO_MUTUAL.
And here so that client
and server, both we
are use expected results.
So let's apply this YAML file.
And as you can see, both
policy and the destination rule
now has been configured.
We are expecting the traffic.
We are shifting from the
plain text to the mutual TLS
Let's verify that on
our Grafana dashboard.
Just it take a couple of seconds
for the CRD from the API server
to go to the pilot and
then goes to Envoy.
Let me refresh it.
Oh, actually, we can see that.
Now the traffic has been swapped
from the yellow to the green.
From the yellow, you can
see that it's nothing there.
But if you hand over
to the green line,
you can see there is a
column, mutual TLS which
means that your traffic now
is encrypted and protected.
And these behaviors, same
consistently regardless
whether you run your VM--
the application's on the VM
or your Kubernetes cluster.
You can see both of them get
swapped from the plain text
mutual TLS.
Awesome.
So we finish the security part.
Now let's talking about
the networking management.
So you run your
applications on the VM.
And you run something on
the Kubernetes cluster.
Imagine that you want to
migrate something from the VM
to the Kubernetes cluster.
And you want to control
this process and [INAUDIBLE]
the migration with competence.
Istio supporters
that while advanced
L7 and routing using
virtual service.
And you just write
some virtual service
CRDs to configure how much
percentage of the traffic
you want to send to the--
and one of the subset which
is Kubernetes cluster,
how much you want to
send to the VM subset.
We also have-- already
have some CRD for that.
Here we go.
So the first part, again,
is the destination rule.
And in the destination rule,
other than the TLS settings,
we also specify two subsets.
The first one is Kubernetes one.
If we use the labels,
labels that's basically
for the workload, that has app
column productcatalogservices
labels that we are--
make that as part of
the Kubernetes subset.
And for the endpoint that
has the registry [INAUDIBLE]
labels, that we are think
that is a rawvm, the vm
part of the subset.
So remember that
the registry column
rawvm, these labels, that
is exactly what you just
put it in the service entry.
Basically, in the
Kubernetes, you
put labels in your deployment.
And in the service entry, we
have the same functionality
for you to attach labels and
use that to define the subset.
Once you define the
subset of service,
you can then use the virtual
service for the routing.
As you can see that for the
Kubernetes subset, we use 80%.
And for the VM part, we use 20%.
So we are expecting after
apply these two CRDs, the more
traffic from 50 will jump to the
80 for the Kubernetes traffic.
And the VM, we get less traffic.
So the configuration
has been applied.
Now what we are expecting
is a dropping line
on the VM Grafana dashboard.
And we will a bump up in
the Kubernetes workload.
So this might take
a couple of seconds.
But here we go.
So you can see the line is
dropping down from around 2 qps
to 1 qps.
And on the other hand,
the Kubernetes workload
is significantly ramp up
because more traffic is routed
to the Kubernetes cluster.
So this seems all right.
And as you have
more confidence, you
can continue to use
the virtual service
to route more traffic to
your Kubernetes version
and finally get rid
of your VM workload.
But that's our demo.
And to summarize, the take away
that you have some VM workload.
And you want to migrate
to Kubernetes cluster.
You want to have
the service mesh
across different environments.
And you may even want to
migrate something from the VM
to the Kubernetes cluster.
And Istio can help you to finish
that journey with confidence
by having telemetry
and showing you what
is going on in that process.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS CRALL: Thanks, Jianfei.
OK.
That was a lot of information
packed into that demo.
We went from essentially
a bare cluster and a VM
to installing Istio and getting
it all configured in five
to 10 minutes and then
actually going through,
showing you an
application, showing you
the features of
Istio, and giving you
all of these features of Istio,
the uniform observability,
the operational agility, and
the policy-driven security
across not only your Kubernetes
cluster, but across your VMs
as well.
Whether it's the
migration scenario
Jianfei just talked about of
how do you take your VM workload
and bring it into the
Kubernetes cluster
over time giving you a
kind of a canary rollout,
or whether it's your
VMs that are going
to continue to run for the next
one, two, five years, whatever
it is with that
database out there,
you can bring those
VMs into to your mesh.
So that's how you make
a hybrid environment.
Jianfei talked about
the documentation.
It's all up here.
The mesh expansion
is a little hidden.
You have to go to
the Kubernetes site.
And then you go to
the mesh expansion.
But that has all
the instructions
on how to do this yourself.
And then there's the
Dory link at the bottom.
[MUSIC PLAYING]